Ils pensent aux immeubles, aux rues
aux gratte-ciel et aux taxis bruyants.
Mais quand je pense à une ville,
je pense aux personnes.
Les villes sont foncièrement constituées de personnes,
et les lieux où ces personnes se rendent
et se rencontrent
sont les noyaux qui font fonctionner les villes.
Ce qui est encore plus important que les immeubles d'une ville
sont les espaces publics au milieu.
Et aujourd'hui, certains des plus grands changements dans les villes
surviennent dans ces espaces publics.
C'est pourquoi je pense que des espaces publics vivants et agréables
sont la clé pour les fondements d'une grande ville.
Ils sont ce qui la rend vivante.
Mais qu'est-ce qui fait le succès d'un espace public ?
Qu'est ce-qui attire les personnes dans les espaces publics réussis,
et qu'est-ce qui, dans ceux qui ne le sont pas,
éloigne les gens ?
Je pensais que si je pouvais répondre à ces questions,
je pourrais apporter une grande contribution à ma ville.
Mais il y a une chose étrange à mon sujet.
c'est que je suis une comportementaliste animale,
et que j'utilise ces talents non pas pour étudier le comportement des animaux
mais pour étudier comment les habitants des villes
utilisent les espaces publics.
Un des premiers lieux que j'ai étudiés
est ce square appelé Paley Park
situé au centre-ville de Manhattan.
Ce petit espace devint un petit phénomène,
et parce qu'il a eu un grand impact sur les New-Yorkais,
il a laissé une forte impression sur moi.
J'ai étudié ce parc très tôt dans ma carrière
car il s'avère qu'il a été construit par mon beau-père,
alors je savais que les lieux comme Paley Park
n'étaient pas là par hasard.
J'ai vu tout de suite qu'ils demandaient
un incroyable dévouement
et un énorme sens du détail.
Mais qu'y avait-il en ce lieu
qui le rendait spécial et attirait les gens ?
Eh bien, je m'asseyais dans le parc et regardais attentivement,
et avant toute chose
il y avait ces chaises, confortables et déplaçables.
Les gens venaient, trouvaient leurs propres chaises,
les déplaçaient un peu, en fait, puis restaient un moment,
et là, se passait un fait intéressant,
les personnes elles-mêmes attiraient d'autre personnes.
Ironiquement, je me sentais plus détendue s'il y avait des personnes autour de moi.
Et c'était vert.
Ce petit parc apportait ce que les habitants de New-York désirent :
du confort et de la verdure.
Mais ma question était :
« Pourquoi n'y avait-il pas plus d'espaces verts
et de lieux où s'asseoir au milieu de la ville
où l'on ne se sentait pas seul,
ou comme un intrus ? »
Malheureusement, ce n'est pas ainsi que les villes ont été conçues.
Alors, là vous avez une vue familière.
C'est comme ça que les places ont été conçues pendant des générations.
Elles ont ce style spartiate
que nous associons souvent à l'architecture moderne,
mais ce n'est pas surprenant que les personnes
évitent les lieux comme celui-ci.
Ils n'ont pas seulement l'air désert,
ils ont carrément l'air dangereux.
Je veux dire, où est-ce que vous vous assiériez ?
Qu'y feriez-vous ?
Mais les architectes les adorent.
C'est le socle de leurs créations.
Ils y toléreront une sculpture ou deux,
et c'est tout.
Et pour les promoteurs, ils sont parfaits.
Il n'y a rien à arroser ou à entretenir,
et pas de gens indésirables dont il y ait à se soucier.
Mais vous ne pensez pas que c'est un gâchis ?
Pour moi, devenir une urbaniste
signifiait d'être capable de vraiment changer la ville
où je vivais et que j'aimais.
Je voulais pouvoir créer des lieux
qui vous donneraient les mêmes sensations
qu'à Paley Park,
et empêcher les promoteurs de construire des places lugubres comme celle-ci.
Mais après plusieurs années,
j'ai appris combien il était difficile
de créer des espaces publics efficaces, censés et agréables.
Comme je l'ai appris de mon beau-père,
ils ne sont pas le fruit du hasard,
spécialement dans une ville comme New York,
où les espaces publics doivent d'abord se battre pour exister,
et ensuite pour être efficaces,
quelqu'un doit donc penser très fort
à tous les détails.
Bon, les espaces ouverts dans les villes sont des opportunités.
Oui, ce sont des opportunités pour des investissement commerciaux,
mais ils sont également des opportunités pour le bien commun
de la ville,
et ces deux buts ne sont que rarement en accord l'un avec l'autre,
et c'est là que naît le conflit.
La première occasion pour laquelle j'ai dû me battre
pour un grand espace public fut aux débuts des années 80,
quand je dirigeais une équipe d'urbanistes
pour une gigantesque décharge nommée Battery Park City
dans le Lower Manhattan sur l'Hudson.
Ce désert de sable avait été laissé stérile pendant 10 ans,
et on nous a dit qu'à moins de trouver un promoteur
dans les six mois, il ferait faillite.
Alors on a eu une idée radicale,
presque folle.
Au lieu de construire un parc
comme complément d'un futur complexe,
pourquoi ne pas inverser le problème :
construire d'abord un lieu public ouvert qui soit petit mais de très haute qualité.
et voir si ça faisait changer les choses.
Nous ne pouvions nous offrir l'édification que d'une section de deux blocs
de ce qui deviendrait une esplanade de 1,6 km,
Peu importe ce que nous fassions, cela devait être parfait.
C'est pour en être sûre que j'ai insisté
pour que nous fassions une maquette
en bois, à l'échelle, de la balustrade et du mur.
Et lorsque je m’assis sur ce banc de test
avec le sable tourbillonnant toujours autour de moi,
la balustrade était exactement au niveau des yeux,
bloquant la vue de la rive et gâchant mon expérience.
Vous voyez donc que les détails font la différence.
Mais le design n'est pas juste de prévoir à quoi cela ressemblera,
mais comment votre corps se sentira assis dans cet espace,
et je pense que le succès de le design dépend toujours
de cette expérience individuelle.
Dans cette photo, tout semble terminé,
mais cette arête de granit, ces lumières,
l'arrière de ce banc,
les plantations d'arbres,
et les différentes manières de s'asseoir
sont toutes les petites batailles qui ont fait que ce projet
est devenu un lieu où les gens ont envie d'être.
Ça s'est avéré très profitable 20 ans plus tard
quand Michael Bloomberg me demanda d'être
sa déléguée à l'urbanisme
et me chargea de la modélisation
de toute la ville de New York.
Il m'a dit quelque chose ce jour-là,
il m'a dit que New York projetait
de passer de huit à neuf millions d'habitants.
Et il m'a demandé :
« Alors où comptez-vous mettre
un millions d'habitants en plus ? »
Eh bien, je n'en avais aucune idée.
Vous savez que New York
se fait fort d'attirer les immigrants,
alors nous étions excités par la perspective de s’agrandir,
mais honnêtement, où allions-nous nous agrandir
dans une ville qui s'était étendue jusqu'à ses limites
et entourée par l'eau ?
Où trouver des logements
pour tous ces nouveaux New-Yorkais ?
Et si nous ne pouvions nous étaler,
ce qui était probablement une bonne chose, où pouvions-nous trouver ces logements ?
Et qu'en serait-il des voitures ?
Notre ville ne pouvait supporter plus de voitures.
Alors que pouvions-nous faire ?
Si nous ne pouvions nous étendre, nous devions nous élever.
Et si nous devions nous élever, nous devions le faire là où
il n'y avait pas besoin d'une voiture.
Ce qui signifiait utiliser l'un de nos plus grands atouts :
notre système de transport.
Mais nous n'avions jamais pensé
au moyen d'en profiter au maximum.
C'est là que se trouvait la réponse à cette énigme.
Si nous canalisions et redirigions
toutes les nouvelles expansions autour des transports,
nous pouvions en fait supporter cette augmentation de population,
c'est ce que nous pensions.
Et voici le plan,
ce que nous devions vraiment faire :
nous devions refaire le zonage --
et le zonage est l'outil habituel des urbanistes --
et basiquement, réorganiser la ville entière,
en ciblant les lieux des nouveaux développements
et empêchant une quelconque expansion
dans notre quartier pavillonnaire de quartier adapté aux voitures
Eh bien, c'était une idée incroyablement ambitieuse,
ambitieuse parce que les communautés
devaient approuver ces plans.
Comment allais-je faire pour y arriver ?
En écoutant. Alors j'ai commencé à écouter.
En fait, des milliers d'heures d'écoute
pour établir la confiance.
Vous savez, les communautés peuvent dire
si vous comprenez ou pas leur voisinage.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que vous pouvez simuler.
Alors j'ai commencé à marcher.
Je ne peux dire combien de quartiers j'ai traversés,
par des étés étouffants, par des hivers glaçants,
année après année,
avec pour seul but de comprendre
l'ADN de chaque quartier
et savoir ce que désirait chaque rue.
Je devins une passionnée experte de zonage,
découvrant comment le zonage pouvait aborder
les soucis des communautés.
Petit à petit, quartier par quartier,
bloc de maison après bloc,
nous commençâmes par fixer les hauteurs
pour que toutes les futures extensions
soient prévisibles et proches des transports en commun.
Au cours de ces 12 ans,
nous avons été capables de rezoner
124 quartiers,
40 % de la ville,
12 500 pâtés de maisons, ce qui fait que maintenant,
90 % de tous les nouveaux développements de New York
sont à 10 minutes de marche du métro.
Autrement dit, personne dans ces nouvelles constructions
n'a besoin de posséder une voiture.
Ces rezonages étaient épuisants,
énervants et importants
mais le rezonage n'a jamais été ma mission.
Vous ne pouvez ni voir ni sentir le zonage.
Ma mission a toujours été de créer
de grands espaces publics.
Dans ces zones que nous avions réservées à des développements significatifs,
j'étais déterminée à créer des lieux
qui feraient une différence dans la vie des gens.
Là vous pouvez voir ce qui était
trois kilomètres d'une berge abandonnée et dégradée
dans le quartier de Greenpoint
et Williamsburg dans Brooklyn,
impossible d'y aller et impossible à utiliser.
Là-bas le zonage était important,
alors je me suis sentie dans l'obligation de créer
des parcs magnifiques sur ces berges,
et j'ai dépensé un temps incroyablement long
sur chaque centimètre carré de ces plans.
Je voulais être sûre qu'il y aurait
des allées bordées d'arbres des hauteurs jusqu'à l'eau,
des arbres et des plantations partout,
et, bien sûr, beaucoup, beaucoup de lieux où s'asseoir.
Honnêtement, je n'avais aucune idée de ce que ça allait produire.
Je devais avoir la foi.
Mais j'avais mis tout ce que j'avais étudié et appris
dans ces plans.
Et puis ça a ouvert,
et je dois vous le dire, c'était incroyable.
Les personnes vinrent de toute la ville
pour être dans ces parcs.
Je sais qu'ils ont changé les vies des personnes qui vivaient là,
mais ils ont aussi changé l'image qu'ont ces gens
de leur ville.
Je descends souvent voir les gens
aller sur ce petit ferry
qui navigue entre les arrondissements,
et je ne peux vous dire pourquoi,
mais je suis totalement émue
par le fait que des gens l'utilisent
comme s'il avait toujours été là.
Et là c'est un nouveau parc dans le Lower Manhattan.
Le rivage dans le Lower Manhattan
était en pagaille avant le 11 Septembre.
Wall Street était essentiellement sans littoral
parce qu’on ne pouvait s'approcher de ce littoral.
Et après le 11 Septembre, la ville avait vraiment peu de contrôle.
Mais je pensais que si nous allions
voir la Lower Manhattan Development Corporation
et recevions l'argent pour défricher ces trois kilomètres
de bord de mer dégradé,
cela aurait un effet énorme
sur la reconstruction du Lower Manhattan.
Et ce fut le cas.
Le Lower Manhattan a maintenant un front de mer public
sur ses trois côtés.
J'aime vraiment ce parc.
Les balustrades doivent être plus hautes maintenant,
alors nous avons mis des places assises aux abords,
et vous pouvez être si proches de l'eau
que vous êtes pratiquement dedans.
Et voyez comme la balustrade s'élargit
et s'aplanit afin que vous y posiez votre déjeuner ou votre ordinateur.
Et j'adore quand les gens viennent là
et lèvent les yeux et disent.
« Ouah, c'est Brooklyn et c'est si près de nous. »
Alors, quelle est l'astuce ?
Comment vous faites d'un parc
un lieu où les gens désirent être ?
Eh bien, ça dépend de vous,
non pas comme un urbaniste mais comme un être humain.
Vous ne puisez pas dans votre expertise en design.
Vous exploitez votre humanité.
Je veux dire, voudriez-vous y aller ?
Voudriez-vous y rester ?
Comment voit-on depuis ce lieu ? Comment le voit-on ?
Y a-t-il des gens ?
Est-ce que ça a l'air verdoyant et amical ?
Pouvez-vous trouver votre place où vous asseoir ?
Eh bien, maintenant à travers toute la ville de New-York,
il y a des endroits où vous pouvez trouver votre propre siège.
Là où on avait l'habitude de voir des parkings,
il y a maintenant des cafés qui surgissent.
Là où la circulation de Broadway passait,
il y a maintenant des tables et des chaises.
Là où 12 ans auparavant, les terrasses de cafés n'étaient pas autorisées,
elles sont maintenant partout.
Mais revendiquer ces lieux pour une utilisation publique
ne fut pas simple,
et c'est encore plus dur de faire en sorte qu'ils le restent.
Maintenant, je vais vous parler
d'un parc sortant de l'ordinaire s'appelant le High Line,
qui était une ligne de métro surélevée.
(Applaudissements)
Le High Line était une ligne de métro surélevée
qui traversait trois quartiers
sur l'ouest de Manhattan,
et quand le train cessa de circuler,
ça devint un paysage qui s'ensemença lui-même,
un genre de jardin aérien.
Et quand je le vis pour la première fois,
franchement, quand je suis monté dans ce vieux viaduc,
je suis tombé amoureuse comme on peut l'être d'une personne,
honnêtement.
Et quand je fus nommée, sauver les deux premières sections de la High Line
de la démolition devint ma priorité
et mon projet le plus important.
Je savais que s'il n'y avait pas un jour où je ne me
souciais pas de la High Line, cela adviendrait.
Et la High Line,
bien qu'elle soit désormais largement connue
est un phénomène populaire,
c'est l'espace public le plus contesté de la ville.
Vous pouvez y voir un joli parc,
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde.
Vous savez, c'est vrai que les intérêts commerciaux
seront toujours en lutte contre les espaces publics.
Vous pouvez vous dire :
« C'est si merveilleux que plus de
quatre millions de personnes viennent du monde entier
pour visiter la High Line. »
Mais, un promoteur ne voit qu'une chose, les clients.
Hé, pourquoi ne pas retirer ces plantes
et placer des magasins le long de la High Line ?
Ne serait-ce pas excellent
et cela n'amènerait-il pas beaucoup d'argent à la ville ?
Eh bien non, ce ne serait pas génial.
Ce serait un centre commercial, et non un parc.
(Applaudissements)
Et vous savez ce que pourrait signifier plus d'argent pour la ville,
mais comme la ville doit considérer ses actions sur le long terme,
pour le bien commun.
Plus récemment, la dernière section de la High Line,
la troisième section,
l'ultime section de la ligne,
est entrée en conflit contre les intérêts de promoteurs,
où certains des plus grands promoteurs
construisent plus de 5 millions de mètres carrés
à Hudson Yards.
Ils sont venus me voir et m'ont proposé
de « démonter temporairement »
la troisième et ultime section.
Peut-être que la High Line ne correspondait pas
à leur image d'une ville qui luirait de ses gratte-ciel
sur une colline.
Peut-être que c'était simplement sur leur chemin.
Mais en tout cas, ça a pris neuf mois
de négociations quotidiennes et incessantes
pour finalement avoir l'arrangement signé
d'interdiction de sa démolition,
et c'était il y a deux ans seulement.
Alors vous voyez, qu'importe le niveau de popularité
et le succès des espaces publics,
ils ne peuvent jamais être considérés comme acquis.
Les espaces publics doivent -- voila la portion sauvée --
les espaces publics doivent toujours avoir des champions vigilants,
pas seulement pour les réclamer au début d'utilité publique,
mais aussi pour les concevoir de façon à ce que les gens les utilisent,
et puis pour les entretenir et s'assurer
qu'ils sont pour tous,
qu'ils ne sont pas envahis, violés,
abandonnés ou ignorés.
S'il y a une quelconque leçon
que j'ai apprise de ma vie d'urbaniste,
c'est que les espaces publics ont un pouvoir.
Ce n'est pas simplement le nombre de gens qui les utilisent,
c'est le nombre plus important de gens
qui se sentent mieux dans leur ville
simplement par le fait de savoir qu'ils sont là.
Les lieux publics peuvent changer votre façon de vivre dans une ville,
comment vous ressentez votre ville,
pourquoi vous choisissez une ville plutôt qu'une autre,
et les espaces publics sont l'une des principales raisons
qui vous font rester dans une ville.
Je pense qu'une ville prospère
est comme une fête fabuleuse.
Les gens restent car ils y passent un bon moment.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. (Applaudissements)